OK. We have had a continued explosion with
the David Pakman show. Read it, I guess with
people thing home. A lot of people are hanging
out on Reddit. We now have more than 18000
of our viewers and listeners participating
at David Pakman dot com slash. Read it. A
few posts that caught my eye this morning.
An article from CNN. A group of young adults
held a Corona virus party in Kentucky to defy
orders to socially distance. Now, one of them
has Corona virus. You know, these these stories.
I mean, listen, I never take pleasure in people
getting sick, getting an illness, having to
be hospitalized, dying or anything like that.
If these boneheaded decisions, the decisions
that come from minimizing or even sometimes
mocking coronavirus, if these decisions only
impacted the decision makers, I wouldn't really
care that much like it. You know, I'm not
going to be cheering that these these people,
these young adults get coronavirus, but if
they are the only ones affected by it, OK,
that's a decision that doesn't affect anybody
else. But much like second hand smoke, but
to a much greater degree, they're having and
spreading corona virus will get more people
who will not make it to be infected. It will
get older folks, folks with co-morbidities
who are more likely to die infected. So it's
not fun and games. It's actually disgusting.
There are news reports about teens coughing
on produce in grocery stores. Again, the idea
being we don't care about coronavirus. Maybe
we're putting Corona virus on on your Granny
Smith Apple or whatever the case may be. And
there's a lot of really great people and inspiring
behavior that this is bringing out in our
population. And there's also a lot of really
disgusting stuff that that could not be more
vile. And, you know, unfortunately, this is
one of those things where if we're not in
it together, we ruin it for everybody. It
is. It's sort of like a tragedy of the commons
sort of situation where you might not have
much to lose if you get coronavirus. And so
you benefit by just doing your thing, going
out, hanging out, whatever the case may be.
But that action will hurt others and thus
hurt society in a way that in some way probably
will come back to hurt even these young teens.
In any case, you all know where I where I
come down on this. We've got to just grin
and bear it and stay home. And, you know,
30 of 50 states still haven't even started
doing that. Also from The David Pakman Show,
Reddit, HB 420 posted, Biden leads Sanders
by 18 and 19 in two new polls. How do we blame
the mainstream media for this, given that
Biden has been a while? Where's Joe? And to
the mainstream media has been singularly focused,
uncovered 19. Well, it depends who you ask.
There are people who say before all this got
going, Biden was up 18 or 19. Now no one's
talking about it at all. So Biden remains
up 18 or 19. Now, on the other hand, there
continue to be, you know, a lot of the folks
that believed that during the Bernie Biden
debate, Biden would implode so ferociously
that Bernie would take the lead. Some of those
same folks have been saying Biden's done like
two streams about coronavirus and they've
been terrible where Bernie is doing many more
streams and they're good. This is going to
flip the polling numbers. It just doesn't
seem to be happening for whatever reason.
And now the big question is, will there be
any other debates as we get closer to future
primaries? The one if if primaries stop being
postponed and we were supposed to have one,
two days ago in Georgia, that's been postponed.
Puerto Rico was supposed to vote in three
days. That's been. And I don't know when the
next actual primaries are going to be. Joe
Biden is starting to say, I think we've debated
enough. Bernie Sanders campaign saying, no,
no, debates are good and we will see whether
there is any event that changes the trajectory.
Also, the idea that Corona virus itself will
in many people make it so clear that Bernie's
health care policy would be far better suited
to deal with a pandemic than that of Joe Biden
and that that will create a shift in the polls.
We've been hearing that for 10 days and that
shift has not yet happened. So I remain skeptical
that we are going to see that. Lastly, from
the David Pakman show subreddit. Yes. A user
named Sue but-I 6 1 7 posted a link to the
infamous Ron Paul Corona virus hoax episode
that Ron Paul did. Ron Paul, of course, the
father of Senator Rand Paul. Ron Paul, a former
Republican, Congressman Rand Paul, the current
Republican Senator Rand Paul now has the virus.
And Ron Paul previously called it a hoax.
Now, it's important to mention if you go and
listen to that episode. Ron Paul was not saying
Corona virus itself is a hoax, like denying
that it exists or anything like that. But
he was, of course, taking this kind of wacky
libertarian perspective about how the the
coro exaggeration of the hoax is the way that
corona virus is being used to potentially
encroach on civil liberties. And, you know,
that's sort of the standard libertarian talking
points. Still, the contrast between Ron Paul
publishes an episode called the Corona Virus
Hoax. Rand Paul gets the virus and then continues
hanging out at the Capitol Hill at the Senate
gym and other places after being tested. But
before getting his positive result, not good.
And again, we can't listen to these people.
And I'm glad that most libertarians are shutting
their mouths during this. The anti-vaxxers
also are mostly shutting their mouths. That's
a good thing. But I would expect that to start
to change if this becomes the new normal and
extends for many months, which it very well
might join the discussion at the David Pakman
show. Read it David Pakman dot com slash read
it. That's r e d d i t.